Here's a warning spoiler alert I would
personally like to apologize to starlight
who was wrongfully accused of sabotage
and conspiracy welcome back to the team
the only two words that i've heard from
uh the powers that be about season three
with regards to homelander maniac so
i don't think it bodes well for some people but
what that means we just have to wait and see i'd
like to be back in the seventh so i know it's deep
getting back in it we'll see i mean maybe there's
like a team up you know like uh bad soups versus
uh the good soups we'll see i don't think there's
a lot of loyalty in the seven it's whoever's going
to bring in the cash and she's not gecko she's not
necessarily i think growing her arms back that i
know of but you know i think you just gotta tune
into season three and find out and let me know
am i a part of season three welcome back everyone
it's charlie this is going to be my video for the
boys season three they just released a new teaser
anthony starr talking about homelander aya cash
talking about stormfront some of the other
characters so we'll break it all down if you're
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos i will be doing bonus videos for the
boys season three while we wait for new episodes
to get here but obviously as they say during that
video careful for spoilers for everything that
happens during season two if you haven't seen the
episodes yet so we'll do top 10 wtf questions as
we go along through this starting with number 10
when anthony starr says homelander is going to
be a homicidal maniac during season 3 what is he
actually going to be doing that's different that's
any worse than what he's already been doing this
entire time like who out there does not think that
he has been pretty psychopathic this entire time
that's the whole pitch of the character what if
superman but he's a psycho in fact the scene that
they put in that video there the press conference
at the end of season two where it's zooming in on
his eyes is literally a reference to the ending
of the first alfred hitchcock psycho movie
the main character during that movie wasn't the
actual killer he doesn't become the killer till
the sequels but the ending of that movie is him
being thrown in prison and going full-blown psycho
becoming the killer that everyone thought that
he was so that's basically what they're saying
is happening to homelander in this moment but i
think the difference here that anthony star is
talking about is that it probably means he's going
to be actively going out on the regular looking
for opportunities to kill criminals or create
situations where he's allowed to kill people
whereas before say like the opening scene of
season one is a great example how he really
just didn't care and was mostly going through the
motions but he wasn't actively looking for people
to kill like he's trying to say people here he
wants to be a hero he wants their admiration
but he doesn't have any of the morality of
superman so instead of helping arrest these
criminals he melts the gun into this guy's hand
then uppercuts him down the block onto the car
killing him all without batting an eyelash or
even thinking twice about it and he kind of
isn't even looking at the guy when he uppercuts
him he's kind of turning around when he does it
so he's a psychopath and he's a narcissist but
he isn't going around creating situations just to
kill people for the pleasure of it and during that
video where he says some people aren't going to be
happy about that he's probably talking about maeve
and starlight the other people on the seven the
people within vaught like stan edgar's character
because he wants homelander to do what he tells
him to do it's all about making money as the face
of the seven he's also kind of the face of vaught
they have this entire financial empire that's
sort of built on the seven and these superheroes
so the public's faith in him crumbles it'll also
crumble in vaught vaught will lose all of its
share value and the company will go away and as
we've seen that's the only thing that stan edgar
really cares about is just the company that's
where the contingency of ryan now comes in they
call him baby homelander the actors behind the
scenes which is kind of funny baby homelander
causing all kinds of problems the real question
though is is how powerful is ryan actually as
the world's first naturally born superhero is he
more powerful than homelander up to this point as
far as we've known at least there haven't been
any naturally born superheroes so earlier in
season two when stormfront was telling homelander
about the secret history of vaught in her history
and how he was the culmination of all the work
that they've been doing the real plan really when
you think about it ryan is actually the truest
expression of that because the whole thing now
is that ryan doesn't need compound v to have his
superpowers also big follow-up to that will ryan
now grow faster than a normal human or will he
start to age super slowly making him a child for
the next 50 years is this a baby yoda situation
where he just ages super slow and seems like a
child for a long time i think the answer to that
is mostly no just because of practical filming
reasons in real life so the actor who they cast
for this is obviously going to continue to age up
that's why in a lot of long running series if you
start out with a kid either you have to recast him
with an older actor or there has to be some sort
of time jump or you just write him out of the show
because if a show takes two years to get the next
season out the kid comes back and he's like two
feet taller and it just comes off seeming kind of
weird but because ryan is a superhero they don't
really have that problem logically it would make
sense that he would age up a little bit faster or
at least he would reach maturity faster his
full power level and then he'd start to age
super slowly also funny follow-up question
there was that joke that aya cash said about
stormfront being homelander's secret mother
the deepest homelanders mom i mean two one the
theory about that actually came from the idea that
they actually used stormfront's genetic template
to create home later they used all the genetic
information the science of creating stormfront
perfected that then used that information to
create an even better version in homelander
but homelander himself was actually implanted in
his mother as a fetus like he was grown to term
inside a regular woman's belly but because of the
way they dosed him so heavily with compound v in
the womb his fetus basically grew overnight that's
how quickly he grew inside the womb it was like
pouring water on a sponge and then boom the sponge
just bursts out of his mother's womb that doesn't
confirm that stormfront shares any genetics with
homelander it's just the theory that homelander
has such a mommy complex with all the milk and
just everything that was going on with stillwell
during season one and even during season two with
the doppelganger that having a relationship with
someone who is kind of his secret mother would be
the most homelander thing that you could possibly
do i just love that aya cash herself is sort
of winking at those theories like she's reading
them online like i see what you're saying that
homelander is secretly my son she also obviously
makes jokes about coming back for the boy season
three please tell me if i'm in season three but
clearly that's a joke because she is coming back
for season three the show runner already confirmed
it she's not dead she's stumped front as they
call her now because she has a bunch of stumps
the real question though is is that what is vaught
going to do to her in their secret facility and
what is her power level going to be like will
she be diminished in any way the way that anakin
skywalker was supposed to be at least a little bit
less powerful when he became darth vader somewhat
diminished because of the experience of losing
all those limbs and the trauma of almost dying
as a lot of you have pointed out yes she does have
regeneration powers like homelander lasered her
chest all night long then she came back looking
like she was brand new so how fast does she heal
and what is she going to heal the way the comics
in the tv show have explained it so far is that
it's just like a regular human regrowing damaged
tissue just thousands of times faster so it's not
an unlimited ability like she can't grow her hands
back she could just heal a lot of the damaged skin
so she will have to get prosthetics i know a lot
of you have made jojo's references if you're a big
anime fan jojo's bizarre adventure cyborg nazis
that's all i'll say next big wtf question how
long has victoria newman had compound v powers and
how powerful is she how close does she have to be
what's the proximity the way they've established
her on the show makes it seem like she's had
powers this entire time it's not like a very
recent thing like she grew up with powers and she
understands how to use them pretty well the thing
about the boys tv show that they kind of don't
get across sometimes is that most superheroes the
vaught-sponsored superheroes that get compound fee
don't really know how to be superheroes or even
work with other superheroes on a team it usually
winds up being a giant disaster when they have big
team ups the whole thing with the plane is a big
twist during season 2 and season 3 now hanging
over homelander's head but the whole idea was
is that in season 1 when it actually happened he
was trying to save those people he just did such a
terrible job at it so if it seems like victoria
newman has a deep understanding of her powers
and knows what her limits are then she's probably
had her powers for a long time but i know a lot of
you have also asked can she also kill homelander
because there's almost nobody aside from ryan that
could probably kill homelander right now i think
if you go back and you watch the season 2 episodes
and you re-watch that season 2 episode 5 scene of
them together at the big rally she put on a really
good act now knowing that she has those powers
like she looks afraid when he shows up like oh is
he going to squish me like a bug i think the answer
to that is that she could probably kill him if she
tried but she'd have to move really quickly and
we just don't know exactly what the limits of her
abilities are yet we just know that she's able
to pop people's heads from a distance we don't
know exactly how long it takes what the recharge
rate is for the most part it seems like it has
to be line of sight and it does take a couple
seconds for it to work so homelander is quicker
than that so i think that's the whole thing is
that if he sensed what was happening he could
take her down before she completed the job next
big follow-up talking about jensen ackles soldier
boy how powerful is he going to be compared
to homelander homeland is still technically
supposed to be the most powerful superhero in
the world but the way they talk about jensen
echo's soldier boy character is that he was also
one of the genetic templates for homelander the
showrunner basically said he was homelander before
there was a homelander but that means a couple
different things that means that he was the most
powerful american superhero of his day because it
was world war ii when he was created and two
during that period he was also a pop culture
icon superhero in the way that homelander is the
number one celebrity because he's so powerful
if they're going to be truer to the comics and go
for all the captain america avengers references
then it's very similar to the power level of
captain america like he is super strong but
nowhere near as powerful as homelander but what'll
probably happen in the next couple of days or so
is i'll do another boy season 3 video for payback
and what's going on with that because obviously
that'll bring a whole bunch of new avengers
marvel references to the boys season 3. the way
the showrunner explained it he said that season
3 is going to be even crazier than season two so if
you feel like they really upgraded the wtf level
during season two it'll be even more over the
top next year will you wait for everything click
here for that other boys season 3 teaser trailer
they just released and click here for the boys
season 3 episode 8 finale video in all my other
episode videos thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!